idiome est une ville en grande partie
détruite il n'y a ni eau ni électricité
ni réseau téléphonique cette colline est
le seul endroit où la connexion passe
alors les habitants viennent d'appeler
leurs proches pour beaucoup c'est la
première fois depuis des mois dit
bonjour aux mamans et à grand mère on
tient bon ici ça va aller
sur ce bout de colline il n'y a de temps
que pour les priorités j'aimerais partir
d'ici mais où aller
papa nous dit qu'il faut aller à
kharkhiv et ensuite en europe il y en a
assez de rester planté laayoune
merde il n'y a plus de raison maintenant
que les russes sont partis d'autres sont
déterminés à rester peu importe les
difficultés
on a attendu ce moment tellement
longtemps maintenant on va reprendre nos
vies ensemble ici on attend que nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants nous
rejoigne
pendant l'occupation russe elle venait
parfois ici appelé sa fille à ce moment
là aussi c'était l'unique endroit où
trouver du réseau mais c'était effrayant
vous ne saviez jamais quand ce serait
frappé des gens a été tué pendant qu'il
était au téléphone si vous marchez au
tour vous verrez des impacts par
les bombardements était loin d'être le
seul danger les troupes russes arrêtés
parfois les habitants qui revenaient de
la colline c'est ce qui est arrivé à
anna ils ont lu mes messages dans mon
téléphone ils n'ont pas aimé l'un
d'entre eux qui disaient les orques pour
parler des russes trois groupes sont
venus et on a été détenus dans un sous
sol pendant une demi-journée à ce moment
là sa maison est déjà détruite anna vite
alors dans le sous sol de son voisin
avec soixante et une autre personne le
propriétaire se rappelle de la joie
ressentie à l'annoncé de l'arrivée des
ukrainiens la nuit on a entendu des
véhicules circuler le matin quand on est
sorti des gens disaient qu'il n'y avait
plus de checkpoint sur le pont il
n'était plus là plus à cet endroit et
c'était calme et quand nous avons vu les
ukrainiens je jure que nous nous sommes
juste levé et nous avons pleuré
même si les bombardements sont finis
beaucoup vous restez dans l'abri autour
d'eux mais on se prépare tous à l'hiver
même s'il n'y a pas de chauffage la
température est toujours de 18 degrés
ici plus même si on respire à 50
les habitants du sous sol ne se
connaissaient pas avant de s'y réfugier
il se considère désormais comme une
feuille